the essential ingredient
to all Innovation is ideas
but how do you come up with ideas
are they good how many should you have
today we'll be talking about the big
idea behind good ideas
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
I am very excited to talk with Jeremy
Utley Jeremy is the director of
Executive Education at Stanford's hasso
platner Institute of Design also known
as the D school where he co-leads the
d-schools launch pad Venture accelerator
he hosts Stanford's masters of
creativity web series I look forward to
talking about that and along with Perry
claibon he recently published the book
idea flow the only business metric that
matters welcome Jeremy thanks for being
here I'm super excited for our
conversation yeah me too thanks for
having me let's jump in you seem to have
found a great Niche for yourself
straddling the business and creative
worlds and I know you have some strong
beliefs about innovation in business can
you share your perspective and what
mindset you suggest people take when it
comes to innovation in business
yeah a lot of people say I'm an ideas
guy and not me I mean people call me an
idea but people say of themselves I'm an
ideas guy I love ideas I respectfully
say no you don't oh you are an idea guy
and it's a key distinction all over the
world doesn't matter where I am it
doesn't matter what culture it is when
people ask me what I do I say I help
people come up with ideas and
universally I get the same response if
I'm in Japan or Hong Kong or Des Moines
Iowa how do you come up with good ideas
and you know I say who said anything
about good
I didn't say I hope people come up with
good ideas I see when people say I'm an
ideas guy what they mean is they like
new things what I'm saying when I say no
you're not you're an idea guy I'm
speaking of a cognitive truth which is
every single one of us it's not an
accusation I'm as guilty as anybody else
every single one of us is prone to what
Abraham luchens in 1942 called the
einstalling effect tell me about that
well I like to think of it as an
anti-einstein effect it's what keeps us
from our most breakthrough opportunities
and what luchens demonstrated and what
researchers at Oxford have subsequently
demonstrated is that human beings when
they think of a solution to a problem
one they stop thinking of other
Solutions and two they're incapable of
seeing better Solutions so they really
lock in on that one solution So when you
say you're an ideas guy I like to joke
no you're not you're an idea guy because
I am too which is to say the tendency of
the human brain is to fixate it on the
first solution that comes to mind and
yet there's very little research almost
none that suggests that there's any kind
of quality and time Association meaning
the best ideas don't come first in fact
there's a fascinating piece of research
called the creative Cliff illusion where
the researchers demonstrated that the
typical person they have this
expectation that your creativity will
precipitously decline at some point it's
a cliff the reason they call it the
illusion though is because it's actually
not true your creativity doesn't decline
hardly at all let alone precipitously
and in fact
there are some people for whom there's
actually a creative ramp where
creativity increases over time you know
who those people are tell me they're the
people who expect they'll keep having
good ideas ah so the mindset of expect
okay I'm seeing how you're building your
answer so what is that mindset that
helps us create more and more ideas and
not be blinded by the first one that
pops into our head exactly it's it's
shifting orientation and that's really
at the heart of Ideal flow the human
tendency is to fixate on the right
answer and very few problems we face in
business or in life have a single right
answer sure it's not like it's not like
math I mean and by the way even advanced
math doesn't have a single running at
the right right it blows your mind but
most people think can I just look in the
back of the textbook and see that I get
it right yes and that's the wrong way to
approach like what the subject line of
this email should be there's no right
answer how I open this presentation
there's no right answer how I give this
piece of feedback there's no so forget
even new products and new services if
you think about the problems most
managers or professionals face they're
problems of I'm trying to solve this
thing right now and if they're aware
that their tendency is to fixate on the
answer if they shift their mindset and
say instead of trying to come up with
the right answer I'm going to try to
generate as many as I can possibly think
of
that actually has it's called what
luchens refer to as an interrupt effect
it interrupts your cognitive tendency to
fixate on a first idea but the important
thing is you're actually Shifting the
goal posts you're saying instead of
looking for the right answer I'm trying
to generate as many possible answers as
I can
and we codify that in the book in a
practice that we call the daily idea
quota where we say every day articulate
one problem that's for which you're
trying to find the right answer and just
shift your mindset and say I'm going to
come up with 10. and 10 is somewhat
arbitrary in the sense that it could be
a hundred or it could be 20 but it's
more than one it's more than one and
it's enough that people kind of run out
of steam maybe they have one or two or
three
but then they've got to force themselves
to think beyond their current
consideration set and that's where the
interesting stuff happens and so it's
really that shift in goal that we're
advocating as kind of a fundamental
capacity building whether you solve the
problem or not what you have to know is
what you're doing with the daily idea
quota is you're retraining your tendency
to fixate on the first thing you think
of and if you solve the problem great if
you don't you're building the muscle and
that's the important thing so you're
training your brain to fight a cognitive
habit that we have exactly
it's about practice I don't know if
you've ever read The Klutz guide to
juggling yeah okay so I so John Cassidy
he's one of the instructors of the
d-school I know him well he wrote The
Klutz guide the whole first chapter of
The Klutz guide you throw the ball in
the air and you let it hit the ground
whole first chapter you do it hundreds
of times and I asked Cass why do you do
that people have to be desensitized to
the ball hitting the ground you can
never learn how to juggle if you're not
comfortable with the ball hitting the
ground right there's something of that
function being performed by a daily idea
quota the cost of writing down a bad
idea is basically zero the potential
benefit of allowing your brain to
increase in variation is enormous the
world doesn't end if I write down a
Dopey idea right you know I do I throw
the Post-it away it doesn't matter but
do I allow myself to entertain Dopey
enough to be brilliant that's really the
question that's fantastic you took me
back to one of my favorite movies The
Karate Kid and the repetition over and
over again to get used to that that's
great maybe that's why I'm such a lousy
juggler I I never practice dropping the
ball you gotta do it right yeah to do it
and it costs nothing that's right that's
the thing except you're like cringe
sense of like oh I failed again and as
long as you think failure is a bad thing
or a bad idea is a bad thing you're not
going to do it but if you realize it's a
necessary input to an innovation process
or a funnel then you embrace it as much
as you embrace the good stuff do you
have
further
ideas and practices for and generating
ideas I like the daily list that's great
are there other things that we can do to
help strengthen that muscle to make
ourselves more comfortable with idea
generation yeah a couple things come to
mind one is be thoughtful about inputs
okay whenever we think about creativity
and Innovation everybody's consumed with
output right what happens right what
designers know and what what the
d-school does such a good job of
emphasizing is input matters the inputs
to your thinking Drive the outputs of
your thinking sure so if you're exposing
yourself to the same inputs you
shouldn't be surprised if you're getting
the same output if you're trying to
increase the variability of the output
then a simple question to ask is where
can I go to learn something new and
there are tons of tools in the book tons
of tools we teach a couple of simple
examples I'll give you one is what we
call a Wonder wander
I wonder wonder okay so you take a
problem in mind or take a problem in
hand and you walk a city block okay and
as you walk the city block you look and
you see an Adidas store you say how
would Adidas deal with this you see a
UPS truck drive by how would UPS do this
you see a children's playground what
would it how does what does a playground
have you almost
imputes or project a sense of divine
inspiration on everything you see and
what are you doing there you're
entertaining new connections so
fundamentally what is an idea an idea is
a connection that's it the brain doesn't
make new material from nothing there's
no such thing as ex nihilo Creation in
human beings okay it doesn't exist right
what the brain does is it takes things
we know and it snaps them together so
that's the heart of a Wonder Wanderer
the other tactic I mentioned is change
your collaborators if you picture your
Wonder Wanderers you're going about the
block and you're Gathering Legos and
you're putting them in your bag well
when you change collaborators a new
collaborator brings a new bag of Legos
and all of a sudden I can try my Legos
on with yours right if the context is
right and so thinking about being being
thoughtful about who am I collaborating
with who am I interacting with if it's
the same people the same team doing the
same thing shocker if we keep saying the
same ideas right and you look across
history see fantastic examples
I think about Ben Franklin who every
single week for 30 years met with a
junto he called it which was a group of
leather apron individuals from other
organizations who would sit down in
Philadelphia and they would say on a
regular weekly basis has anybody moved
here that we ought to know has anybody's
business failed and why is that are
there any scientific advances that would
be relevant to our businesses right for
30 years they met every week and you
wonder how did Franklin come up with the
lightning rod and map the Gulf Stream
and the Continental Congress and fire
departments right it's because his
portfolio of collaborators was so Broad
and one of the things especially in cut
of this hyper efficient moment we are in
right in the professional world we don't
have time to go for a walk we don't have
time to meet with people if unless it's
clearly indirectly related to the thing
I'm working on right now we're not
interested in more Legos and then what
we do is we sit around go why don't I
have any new ideas well you've been
pushing all the other Lego piles away I
love your example of Legos I'm a big fan
of not only Lego bricks themselves but
the company and how they do what they do
and especially around communication I
was introduced to you through a mutual
friend Brendan Boyle who heads up ideas
play lab and he shared he shared
appeared two additional techniques that
I'd love just to get your opinion on for
generating ideas one is just a mashup
where you just generate different ideas
and then see what happens when you
combine them together so think of
animals and then think of furniture and
what happens if you were to combine
those and see and then the other thing
he shared with me which I get very
excited about is thinking through
analogies yes yes and he shares this
wonderful story that I love and I'm
wondering if you know the story as well
as some hospital was looking to make
itself more efficient it's ER rooms
emergency rooms more efficient and
rather than going to other hospitals to
see what they do they went to a Formula
One pit crew yeah and so what does a pit
crew do right and they they notice lots
of things like they kit things together
and people have specific jobs and they
stay in specific places and it had a
dramatic impact on the ideas they
generate yeah what the research suggests
is the more distant the analogy the more
breakthrough the results Arthur kosler
who's a philosopher and author who wrote
a fantastic book called The Act of
Creation 800 page tone on creativity one
of the things he said that he defined
creativity as the Collision of
apparently unrelated frames of reference
and so if you think about apparently
unrelated being I mean obviously
Collision being the the active verb
there right but apparently unrelated
right what does NASCAR have to do with
the hospital it actually has everything
to do with it and if you only think
about superficial characteristics of an
analogy you're stuck going to what about
nursing homes right and what about
birthing centers right it's all because
you're thinking health care right right
but if you start thinking about the
deeper
characteristics of the problem to be
solved this is about fast turns why
don't we go to Southwest Airlines right
maybe we could learn there right this is
about getting somebody in and out as
quickly as possible well let's not go to
the DMV right whatever the case may be
but so thinking about the
characteristics of your problem often
yields and the research suggests when
analogies were imposed
that are farther afield than folks
expect the ideas were much more creative
than analogies were that were kind of
typical and standard I think many people
who resonate with what you're saying and
can see the value in it are confronted
with bosses or infrastructure that
aren't about that how do you convince
persuade cajole prove that these ideas
that you're talking about can actually
make a big difference for somebody who's
not of that mindset yeah you're right
that the environment
determines a lot of your success right
so there's a couple of things here one
is the environment matters and if you
look at for example educational
interventions the single greatest
variable that affects the success of the
educated is the context into which they
are sentenced so you can teach somebody
anything fascinating if they go into a
context and hostile to it they will
revert back to average Behavior as a
kind of playful aside in the context of
marriage what I've noticed is you know
respectfully my wife will say hey we're
not at the d-school right now like we
got to decide we're having for dinner
and like I don't want to brainstorm
right so you got to be willing to say it
takes two to tango and sometimes we
don't have to Tango you know we're just
gonna go Chipotle right it's cool
inaction is often rewarded in
organizations and in Innovative
organizations inaction is punished doing
nothing is not okay The Telltale sign
that inaction is valued is at the end of
a meeting what happens in many
organizations there is a resolution to
have another meeting yes let's talk
about this next week what does that mean
we're not taking action and so what
Innovative leaders do is they end the
meeting by saying what data do we need
between now and the next meeting and
who's going to create it and how are you
doing it they establish ownership they
establish accountability if we don't
have new information we're not going to
have a new conversation the Innovative
leader is the one who says has an
instinct to go get new information
before the next conversation I want to
turn our Focus very specifically to
communication that you are a master
Communicator our audience is hearing
that and you're great at telling stories
what advice do you have for listeners to
help them communicate in general better
but communicate creative ideas better a
couple things come to mind one is I
think communication is ultimately about
energy transfer you're trying to get
your audience or recipient to feel the
same degree or be energized to the same
extent you are so if you take that as a
premise then the question is do I feel
energy about this I cannot transfer what
I don't possess if I want to transfer
energy then I gotta find what what's
invigorating to me about this right so
tapping into your own authentic
motivation is critical and I would say
the reason for a lot of failures in
innovation in industry is nobody
actually really cares there's not that
fundamental care so that's one thing in
terms of communicating creative ideas
you have to start with why I mean it's
Simon cynic right but a lot of times we
start with the user in the d-school the
human being who is affected I do not by
the way believe that that's the only way
to come up with new ideas we often say
you know you got to start with somebody
other than yourself and yet history is
littered with examples people who design
for themselves and worked really well so
I don't believe that it's always got to
be about the user but you do have to
start with emotion is the one thing I
would say and the tendency in business
is to be sterile in our communication we
want only the facts and so for a lot of
people when they're communicating a
creative idea they talk about what's new
they talk about the technology but if
you don't talk about the emotional
reason for being that emotional impact
that it's going to have on human being
you're going to fail to Rally that that
engagement from your audience and you're
going to fail to transfer energy I love
that notion of transferring energy and I
find I absolutely resonate that emotion
is critical in communication and in the
work I do with my students and the
people I coach who are technologists or
scientists they often bristle at this
notion of emotion because it's about
bits and bytes and in fact I help them
shift by simply saying if you're saving
trees saving lives saving money saving
energy you're actually doing something
emotional there and tap into that first
absolutely as a way and I hear what
you're saying Echoes that as well
I want to turn now to your masters of
creativity web series I've had a lot of
fun watching it and I've learned a ton
I'm curious to hear from you if you
could share one or two of your favorite
lessons you know I think one of the most
fascinating examples that I've heard is
Lighty clots he's a professor at the
University of Virginia he talks about
how the human tendency when we're trying
to make an improvement we have a
tendency to add and what his research
and he had a landmark cover story on
nature the scientific journal sure the
same week that this book was published
on the same topic which was this idea of
subtraction many times the most elegant
solution is to actually remove something
not to add something and yet our
tendency is always to add that to me is
profound implications for a lot of
innovation efforts before we end I'd
like to ask you the same three questions
I ask everybody who joins me are you up
for that sure
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be show me
your soul
I was impacted by that line the creative
director of the d-school Scott dorley in
an impassioned moment at a critical
juncture in our organization's history
made a plea for more Soulful work and it
often comes to mind I don't even know if
I've gotten it right verbatim but that's
what I took away from it was and to me
it's this sense of care do you even care
about this and I really feel that's
integral as I said earlier to
communication that sense of that's the
nuclear reactor at the center that has
the not to make a political statement
all I mean is that's what will generate
un incomparable energy is that sense of
soul that sense of care very powerful
and very evocative the the analogy you
used question two who is a communicator
that you admire and why uh my dad
definitely he has a masterful way of
getting folks to stay engaged he was a
preacher when I was growing up and I
that's a preacher's you know job if
folks are falling asleep in the pews
you're in trouble right although that
happens a lot unfortunately but he's
since moved on to other professions but
everybody's got a repertoire of stories
and my dad included he always he's
adding new stories about right obviously
but one of the things I've realized is
he'll be telling a story and I know that
I know it already but I don't interrupt
him because I'm trying to figure out
what is the arc here that makes people
lean in and I feel like I've learned
even subconsciously a lot of my own
storytelling technique from how he
taught me almost in more of an
apprenticeship model I think it's
wonderful that you admire your father in
his storytelling all parents should
strive to have their kids admire
something about them yeah but what I
find fascinating is that you're actually
looking at the the technique structure
of the story as well and and that's
important and that's something we've
talked a lot about on this show
let me ask question three what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
what when and why all right I think
being simple right but to me if you're
gonna be successful you're hopefully at
the end of the day you want to change
something in terms of action or behavior
I think that's communication right is
hopefully to change something so if it's
in the bowl of action so to speak then
what is the change right when does it
have to happen and why do I want it to
happen and maybe a little bit of a
superficial answer but to me it's I
don't think that's superficial at all I
think that's actually really insightful
the piece there that we have not heard
in any way shape or form is the when
piece things happen on a timeline with a
sense of urgency or not and you need to
factor that in I appreciate you adding
that to our catalog of things to be
thinking about when we create our
communication recipes well Jeremy it has
been a true pleasure I I appreciate you
bringing your full soul and energy to
this conversation everybody listening
take lots of ideas away for how they can
be more creative and certainly I had a
lot of fun and this dialogue continues
them any that we've had in the past
thank you so much and I wish you best of
luck not only on your show but also on
your new book thank you
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB